royalty hi great to see you again it's
good to see you too Mark it's been a
while it has lots has happened in your
life since the last time you were here
oh hell yeah tell me what's going on
well where should I
start well I there was there was
something that you didn't disclose in
our past talks that maybe would help
this one so last time I asked you if you
had a a pimp who was helping you and you
always said it I prefer not to say right
yes
so um your partner is uh is incarcerated
he's he's in prison right now he has
been for a year and my life
has been very
different um but the little structure
that I do have left in my life is
because of
him but yeah he is one of the sometimes
when I'll say positive things about some
pimps you're he's your boyfriend too
right yeah I mean I wouldn't say he's my
boyfriend like it's not
like he's he's my partner like you said
like we have a
um I mean like I'm I'm a prostitute so I
can't really have boyfriends got it
whatever he he is very he's a very good
dude for
sure he's helped you in many different
ways right yeah tell me some of the
things he's done for you well before
everyone wants to share a bunch of hate
on pimps when I first met him I was
18 um I was struggling with my addiction
I was doing hard drugs I was doing
Crystal and
um well
I wouldn't say that he was like the
reason that I got off because to get off
drugs you have to want to stop yourself
you have to be like I'm just done I
don't want to do this [__] anymore I'm
tired but you also need like the support
from somebody else and he was like my
support system and he helped me um
understand that I was too good for that
and I was going to ruin my life
also um
he just helped me
um see that I was
like a beautiful person cuz sometimes
like even now I like have a really low
self-esteem and he like raised that for
me and it it made me better like at work
and in life and in certain
areas and he's a honest person he's
trustworthy he's Great Communicator he's
intelligent he's respectful yeah yeah
he's just like an overall really good
person yeah that's a great way Des to me
he's it's weird that he's a pimp to me
he's like a father figure like you know
I was telling you this it's like I don't
love him like like a square girl with
her
boyfriend I think it's like a little bit
stronger than that too because he like l
Lally guides me through life and [__]
like that your life has been a lot was a
lot better when he was in it and now
that he's locked up he's you've drifted
yeah I've drifted mhm in what ways I
drank a lot I think like since I seen
you last
time I've been drinking like every day I
drink every day for sure if I don't I'm
in jail but
yeah mhm you're living in Las Vegas now
yes I'm living in Las Vegas um it's
terrible I have an ankle
monitor
um yeah I want to come back to LA but I
had to wait until like October when I
finish all this court
[__] Supreme should be out of prison
next Spring
right um that's what he says yeah as far
as I
know so what are your goals now what do
you want to do well right now I just
want to work on my only fans
um and [__] like
that
basically
yeah so you you have an only fans is it
yeah I have an only fans it's still the
same it's just royalty
Supreme um you can find it on my
Instagram my Instagram is fast stepping
no g at the
end it's in the link do you miss all way
yeah I've been here for um two days now
and I went to Fig and [__] and I don't
care what anybody says people look down
on it so bad but I mean I don't think I
would want to like do it every single
day because once you're somewhere every
single day it just starts to get
irritated and tiring but I love fake and
it loves me
back I make my money and I go home I
sleep good at
night
mhm and your mood I assume you're
depressed or something like that that's
why you're
drinking
um I don't want to
cry but yeah I just be going through it
like I don't
know it's hard to explain like I'm
getting older I'm 21 now so I
just sometimes I just like think about
my past and my
future and it's like I
want I don't know I don't even know how
to explain it and I don't want to cry
and go into detail but yes I'm depressed
but depression is just in your mind I
try to tell myself
like um even though you're feeling
sad life still goes on you still need to
pay your bills [__] still needs to be
done
so I have a cocktail
instead that helps
you um I guess so it starts hurting you
it helps me like um just be more open I
guess cuz I am a very very shy
person have you looked into other ways
of making money I think you mentioned
you working in a brao or you tried it oh
yeah I I tried the chicken ranch it was
nice I mean I liked how like I was able
to work legally um we get STD checks
every week so you have to be cleared
before you go to work and we also get
Sheriff
cards um and then you have to be over 21
and [__] but I wasn't patient and I
left because I just felt like I wasn't
going to reach my full potential there
but I should have stayed I guess I
wouldn't have this ankle monitor on if I
stayed mhm mhm the ankle monitor was for
what for
trespassing trespassing the the the
strip so that's the that's what the
police that the police call you
trespassing when a working girl goes
into a casino um if you are already
banned from there I gu oh you were
banned you're
trespassing um and I had an outou of
corridor
meaning I can't go within like a certain
mile radius of the strip or trop which
is the track in
Vegas and um I was I was going in the in
the area and I kept getting
arrested so they gave me an ankle
monitor you're not allowed to go to the
strip anymore no when I was coming over
here um I had to take a bus because I
can't take planes because they also give
me a phone that's connected to this and
I had to keep it with me
24/7
um so I'm Leaving Vegas and they're they
call me and they're like oh we see
you're on the strip and I'm like I'm
literally like I told you guys I was
going to La and I have to pass the strip
to leave Vegas so the [__] but yeah it's
super Petty like it's it's so
stupid most people when they see me with
it they think I did something crazy but
it's literally just for trespassing do
you ever question this lifestyle that
you've
chosen um
sometimes but it is what it
is
what do you think you'll be doing in 10
years I honestly have no
idea and only fans would be a legal way
of for you to make money right yeah
mhm yeah a lot of girls are doing that
they are and I see that they're like
making a lot of money doing it and [__]
and it could just be simple [__] like I
sometimes I see videos of girls like in
lingerie in the grocery store and [__]
like that like you know shock value [__]
that's what I want to do but I don't
have anybody to like record me doing
that
so but I'll figure it out yeah there's
always a way there's always a way and do
you have anyone now that your partner is
locked up do you have any friends do you
have any family do you have
anyone
um I mean no not really that makes life
harder
I guess so sometimes I feel like having
so many people in your life is just
going to
like I don't know I feel like every time
I try to make friends they're not as
genuine as I
am and I don't like that and I'm not
going to deal with that so that's why I
don't have any
friends M how is working in Vegas
compared to working
fig well well um working the strip is
different I think the only difference is
is that you can like get your whole trap
with one person but you still have to
have the same amount of work ethic and
you know the regular [__] that sex
worker supposed to have to make her
money it's just more glamorous that's
about
it is it a glamorous lifestyle
alog together it can be when you're not
at
work when you're just enjoying your
money
yeah yeah that could be the good
[Music]
part are there emotions that come up
from being a prostitute
that you carry through you know the rest
of your life when you're not
working I
mean no I think that the the only thing
that has changed me is like I really
like I
don't I don't like
men like the majority of
them they just really irritate me men in
general
yeah yeah like I just feel like I can't
live life like normally like sometimes
like normal girls and they get
compliment they're like oh thank you and
I just look at them like why the [__]
are you talking to me I don't get
it you
know I don't know I mean the men that
you're running across though are are
the probably not the best example of men
in general yeah no I like tricks I love
tricks they pay they pay my bills they
get it done but
um everybody else is just a no
because it's like all they want to do
like men they want to have sex with
girls and [__] so it's just
like you're not going to you're not
going to get it from for free from me
like I don't understand that and when
I'm like in the real world that's what
cuz like when I walk down the street and
[__] obviously I'm not like they don't
know that I'm a
prostitute but that's the way that you
see life like you know just having like
a simple conversation with the man just
irritates me because it's like are you
going to give me some money or why am I
doing this right now so you've made the
connection
between sex and money and that
connection is not going to be broken
probably for the rest of your
life probably
not probably not that's what I think
happens with sex workers is once you
connect sex and money then you don't you
don't just go back
to a square life
again yeah you
[Music]
know but
[__] so all you can do is find a better
safer way of doing
it
yeah I mean hopefully like I just want
to get
um more people to like subscribe to my
only
fans and I also need to make more
content but I believe that I could do it
if I really just um buckle down and
because it takes effort you know
everything takes effort but I think the
the people women mostly that are making
real money on only fans are the ones
that are it's a full-time job for them
right they're really focused on making
things happen you're
right they can't just be like oh yeah
I'm gonna do this once in a while yeah
this is a
fact all right royalty well it's great
seeing you again I'm happy that
you're that you're alive you look good
you're not wearing the wigs anymore no
wigs I mean I no makeup no wigs no
lashes no nothing no no nails look at
you the the nails are a bad thing this
is unacceptable but because my nails
should be done oh your nails should be
done but um as far as makeup and stuff I
love makeup and I love wigs but I just
been trying to like
um like just be myself you know good for
you yeah and they started making me look
older so I was like no you're still only
21 yeah I feel like I'm like 40 though
like I feel old as [__] you've seen a
lot it is what it
is
MHM all right Royal team well thank you
so much for checking with us and uh
hopefully your partner will be out soon
and you guys can
move on to the next chapter hopefully
something safer and better yeah thank
you
Ros